grid cells are type of brain cell and
first of all they were discovered in
rodents but now we know they exist in
mammals in general they seem to be very
important for sort of measuring out
space our good analogy is that they're
like the grid lines on a map except on a
map we've used square grid lines and the
brains using hexagonal grid lines and
you have small scale grid lines and
larger scale grid lines originally
people used to think they were very
important force that we call path
integration which is basically updates
where you think you are based on how
you're moving so I know where I am right
now and if I move it 10 meters then I
end up somewhere over there but actually
we're moving beyond that now while we
still think path integration is
important focusing on the fact that we
believe they function like a map they
sort of relate one place to another they
also seem to be very important for
planning routes so if you wouldn't know
the shortest route between here and
somewhere else that you've visited then
the grid lines would provide you with
something called a vector based
navigation and allow you to calculate
the direct line distance with the recent
paper we were trying to do several
things so first of all we were trying to
test this idea of vector based
navigation so our grid cells really the
substrate and machinery that allows you
to sort of calculate these direct line
routes between places but equally we're
trying to do think a little bit more now
we were trying to see if you could take
what we know about how the mammalian
brain works and incorporates it into
artificial agents to improve the way
that they work in this case the way they
navigate first of all we were able to
show that if we trained an agent or a
network to paths integrate then we found
that actually developed grid cells so
this is remarkable convergence of form
in that they looked like red cells in
the mammalian brain they had the same
hexagonal pattern with more tightly
tessellated fields and then we were able
to take that network and transfer into a
larger network that was now controlling
an agent navigating around and that
agent was then able to navigate flexibly
and demanding virtual environments and
so for example one of the tests that we
wanted to see whether to do is whether
it could take shortcuts we had eight
environments that would change while the
agent was in there so it might find one
long route to the goal but then a new
door would open up presenting a shortcut
so the agent with grid cells could
utilize that shot
go straight through to the goal so this
is important for several reasons we've
confirmed that grid cells are important
for database navigations we've shown
that we can use an artificial network to
conduct neuroscience experiments but
also we've shown that incorporating what
we know about how the brain solves a
problem into an artificial network can
provide that network with abilities that
wouldn't have otherwise have had
[Music]